(mellow music)
- [Voiceover] I'm a veteran,
the horse is a veteran
and I can't think of a
better place that he would be
than under my care.
- [Voiceover] This horse
Quincy is part of an elite
squad of horses in the military.
They're called the Caisson
horses of The Old Guard.
They participate in full honors funerals
at Arlington National Cemetery.
Over the course of their service,
each horse walks in thousands of funerals.
When horses retire,
they need a place to go.
So The Old Guard has introduced
the Caisson Adoption
Project to ensure each horse
is given to their perfect forever home
to enjoy their well-earned retirement.
And that's where George comes in.
Today he's taking Quincy home.
- We're a very patriotic family.
The flag flies on the farm everyday
and it just became a unique
opportunity for another
veteran to retire on the farm.
This is a long process,
they're federal property.
That's why they spend so much time
on making a decision to
ensure that these horses
will be taken care of for their lifespan.
I found out through my
daughter that the horse
had some health problems
and what they call
navicular disease, which is
nerve damage on their hoof
and the farm is a rehab farm
for horses with foot problems
and many medical problems.
She thought it would be an ideal place for
the horse to come and live.
He has his dog tags just like he did
when he was in the service on his halter.
Only that the dog tag now
reads “Retired Veteran”.
Quincy will spend the rest
of his life on the farm
as my companion and, as long
as he has a quality of life,
he will live on the farm forever.